there is a new study released by the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences claiming that one in 25 of
people that are sentenced to death are
actually innocent that's 4% so from 1973
to 2004 1.6 percent of those sentenced
to death in the u.s. 138 prisoners were
exonerated and released because of
innocence death sentences account for
12% of known exonerations of innocent
people from 1989 to 2012 the study
concluded that the criminal justice
system goes to far greater lengths to
avoid executing innocent defendants than
to prevent them from remaining in prison
indefinitely okay so there's a lot of
stuff here so again I want to start with
the broad thing where do you guys stand
on capital punishment I have a feeling I
know but but perhaps I don't rip them to
let you take this one first I believe
you have the right in the moment to
defend yourself like to animals and in
that split second if I got to do
something terrible so I stopped
something terrible I have to do it but
later as an act of revenge I don't know
you know and there are the dodgy cases
they so evil there's no fixing them the
problem with it is it opens the gate to
a system that goes yes take the one bad
guy and five normal good ones too and
I'll take some of these now and then
I'll privatize and just start hoarding
to kill netting people in to keep my
lights on yeah which is what we're doing
the privatized prison thing which is a
whole other topic topic but it's the
same mentality of seek the reason for
yeah you built it now look for a reason
to use it yeah it's it's it's it's it's
like the marijuana laws there's no logic
there's no rationality around the stuff
it's it's pure emotion you know the drug
laws are all based on you know wanting
to control populations through that and
this is the same thing there's no actual
proof of anything that this reduces
crime the people who are enforce the you
know law and order people who actually
work in law and order are against it
because they know it doesn't reduce
crime it costs more to have it it's it's
the most irrational system possible and
I don't want the state
charge of deciding who's with this new
study this means that there's a good
percentage of people who are definitely
innocent and are being put to death yes
so I really for yours before that yeah
they're mostly dead in here like half of
them you know their spirits gone and
it's just a shuttle by the time you kill
their you know right and being look
being put in jail for life isn't that
much better obviously but at least
you're breathing so it's a little bit
better super I totally agree with it and
it is cheaper which also makes no sense
but that's another thing about our
legalism should be you know if those
other people up for death row from Wall
Street I might have got it all worked
out with industrial California would
save 1 billion dollars over five years
by replacing the death penalty with
permanent imprisonment alright so that
being said so if you take that so if you
take the financial angle and you take
the 4 percent which is a big number it
is do you think there's any number that
would flip the the people that are for
the death penalty is there any number if
that got up to ten percent because I
don't think they would change their mind
I don't think there's any empirical
evidence that would cause them to change
their money I think people who believe
that an eye for an eye is right is just
the way they believe and they don't care
how many innocent people have to be I
guess not Superman the new collateral
damage Superman he's mad that some guy
knocked his mom over so he goes through
three apartment buildings you know blows
one end and out the other with my kids
cradle and you know whatever you did
something to me personally and this is
purse crash bang people do you think
Superman kills me I just watch it did
you just see the building's you went
through October buildings corn silos
were ruining life that does shut the
farmer whose corns only bought I'm sorry
they seem a tiny friend mentality that
mentality is the same thing as I am you
know we are doing this for your own good
a lot of you got to die for your own
good a lot of the innocents have to do
it to protect you it's becoming evident
it's a broken system in thinking
and as we know the culture wars right
now is Old Testament verses rational
science people that's where we are in
America for 30 years and it's it's
heating up now and but it just because
it becomes so obvious you know when you
look at just the numbers and then today
last night of course in Oklahoma yeah
horrific horrific they went to execute
this man and they've got new medicine
and he woke up and he was twitching and
everything and then when a heart attack
40 minutes later really like do we think
that maybe that qualifies is cruel and
unusual punishment and you know if the
death penalty was so good maybe they
wouldn't have to do the thing where the
people that all press the button at once
so you don't know who actually did it or
the firing squads right where some of
the people have blanks because they
don't want to live with so if it was
really okay you it seems like you'd be
able to find more people willing to
actually kill them right ya know it's
it's and then the fact that she's she's
not stopping executions in her state
they're just gonna wait two weeks and
try to sort this out yeah because that
should probably what do we do what do we
do to reform some of these people cuz
yeah there are the people maybe the
Hannibal Lecter's you know that really
can't be reformed or ever put back into
society but we have a plenty of people
that go to jail for life or go to jail
for half their lives that that can be
reformed and it seems like we make
people more hardened criminals when
actually hobos the institutionalism what
happens in those walls of those prisons
changes people they go from humans to
animals I was just watching a frontline
the other night about solitary
confinement and it it dehumanizes these
people to the point where I can't
imagine them ever functioning outside
those walls again I don't know what the
answer is it's it's you know that's a
form of torture yeah do what they do to
Americans a lot of torture stops
happening no Americans all the time yeah
a lot more and more and more of it like
against all treaties everywhere yeah why
are we closing that Gitmo what happened
who was the guy that said it he does
start with the weird name right there
yeah